to talk more about this i'm now joined
by darren proctor who is the national
secretary of the rmt union um darren
thanks for thanks for speaking to us i
mean
your members must be devastated how are
they taking the news
absolutely devastated as you say woke up
this morning just thought it was going
to be a normal day for those that were
working on board the vessels there was a
notice that went round
and that got sent to us there's some
shore side members
and then a notification come through of
a company
presentation that was reported by dp
world about the future viability of
piano ferries
that presentation was then given a 10
past 11
and prior to the announcement being made
we've seen arrivals of crew coming in by
cultures and security security and you
know escorting them in the announcement
at 10 past eleven said quite briefly as
of today you're all being made redundant
and we cannot continue with you know big
ukc seafarers on board the vessels and
that was it as abrupt as that as i
probably no consultation no negotiation
no dialogue with any trade union that's
impacted by this
um and that was you know the news that
was broke
so what are you advising members now is
it true you're advising people not to
leave the boats if they're still on
board our members are on board the
vessels you know
absolutely devastated by what's going on
you've got personal belongings on board
the vessel you've got security coming up
we're now
uh trained in in in handcuff and
ballyclavers and stuff absolutely
fearful security and bella club security
and baliclavas we're handcuffs onboard
the vessels are any crew members
handcuffed no not that we know of yet
okay i don't know why they've taken that
approach but they have and this was to
escort the new crew that was coming on
board the vessels that are from from uk
from uk and also from overseas that have
been recruited by a uk agency and has to
sign non-disclosure agreements
devastated
the company says that their current
business in its current state is
unviable with this 100 million pound
loss
in light of the pandemic other travel
firms have been hit too obviously and
what do you make of that well pno has
been financially mismanaged for a number
of years uh and he went in saying that
when they were taking money off the uk
government for um no for the fair loan
stuff you know so the financials of
piano have been under question for a
number of years but you know that's down
to their mismanagement but we could have
sat around the table we could have
discussed this like any normal company
would when there's financial but they've
just bought two new vessels for 200
million and they're supported by dp
world who's you know not short of a
bobber too so what are you going to do
now i mean your your members can't stay
on these boats indefinitely no we've got
members who are getting off now because
of that obviously fearful of the
situation on board and we'll be you know
getting political support we're in
contact with mps locally whether it'd be
dover whole et cetera but also calling
on government for political intervention
so you're gonna fight this we're gonna
fight this all the way this you know we
we can't allow this to happen this you
know puts a
a knife right through the heart of uk
maritime we're supposed to be a maritime
nation we're supposed to be looking
after and building you know the matter
time strategy and putting people at the
heart of this and this is what a a
company that a brand like piano is doing
you know to individuals that are around
us today throwing them on the scrappy
putting you know
the economy of dover effectively
unnoticed because obviously a lot of
them are local she farers that spend
their money in the local businesses i
imagine a lot of them working for pno
for decades i mean a lot of the people
we saw earlier were quite young but
there must be people who have been
working there 20 30 years some haven't
been working there 20 30 years and on
the other end of the scale you've got
individuals two three four years who
thought that they were embarking on a
career in the maritime sector and it was
it was a career for them they've got
mortgages young kids they've been coming
in this building today devastated crying
no wondering what they're going to do
and just the kind of the impersonal
message from piano and the way that
they've gone about this is absolutely
appalling
and would we can we could we see
potentially more disruptions here in
dover like the one we saw this afternoon
most definitely more
more
disruption in dover more disruption
under the port around the uk as a
consequence of piano ferries and their
actions and the way that they've treated
their employees today